je cite du gouvernement australien qui
devra et il va falloir y veiller
largement indemniser navale groupe nous
attendons du reste des précisions de
votre part sur ce point quant au procédé
l'attitude de l'australie est bien
évidemment inacceptable je pense que
tout le monde ici portent le même
jugement je rappelle que le matin même
de l'annoncé de l'annnonce de la
dénonciation du contrat le gouvernement
recevait une lettre des autorités
australiennes se félicitant de l'avancée
du dossier un pays peut bien sûr changer
de politique il peut changer de
stratégie c'est son droit mais il est d
usage et des méthodes or celle ci est
inqualifiable et l'on peut se demander
bien évidemment comment nous pourrons
rétablir des relations de confiance avec
ce pays que nous voyions précédemment
comme un vrai partenaire stratégique
nous vous nous donnerez bien évidemment
votre analyse sur monsieur le ministre
sur ce sujet et d'une manière générale
sur les perspectives de la france dans
l'inde au pacifique
cette situation pose aussi la question
de l'action de nos services
diplomatiques et de nos services de
renseignement dans la connaissance et
dans l'anticipation de cet événement
avons nous réellement été les ducs
d'impact en construction depuis 18 mois
selon les informations qui émerge
aujourd'hui
faut-il ajouter cette humiliation au
camouflet est ce que sur ce point
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez nous
donner des informations précises sur ce
que savait nos réseaux diplomatiques
la ministre des armées nous donnera le
point de vue des services de
renseignement nous ne savons pas pour
notre part ce qui serait le plus navrant
soi que nous n'ayons rien vu venir soit
que nous n'ayons rien pu y faire
la presse fait pourtant état maintenant
de nombreux signes avant coureurs et ce
qu'on n'a pas été capable de comprendre
ces signes si nous les avons perdus
perçue est ce qu'on a fait quelque chose
pour éviter ce désastre notre commission
bien sûr a besoin de mieux comprendre
l'enchaînement des événements et comment
en est on arrivé
à ce point puisque il s'agit quelque
part de notre crédibilité sur la scène
internationale
quant à l'attitude des etats-unis et du
royaume-uni la question posée est celle
de la loyauté
la loyauté que ce doit normalement des
alliés historiques je veux dire que cela
vient juste après le retrait américain
pour ne pas parler de débandade
afghanistan
d'auditionnner ce matin l'ambassadeur
david martinon ainsi que une députée
afghane qui nous a profondément ému
alors là aussi vous nous dire et surtout
que vous revenez de new york où vous
avez eu manifestement un certain nombre
de contacts vous nous direz comment
concrètement restaurer la confiance
après une débâcle suivi d'une trahison
la signature du pacte hocus la relance
du format quad rassemblant etats unis
inde japon et australie montre bien à
quel point le pivot asiatiques
américains l'emportent aujourd'hui sur
les alliances européennes forgé dans la
guerre froide alors nous pensons donc
assez à cet égard que le débat sur le
renouveau politique de l'alliance
initiée par la france en deux en
descente 19 est plus que jamais
d'actualité
il ne suffit pas de se proclamer alliés
il faut aussi agir entre alliés et en
alliés
quant à elle la france est un membre
solide de l'otan solidaire loyal nous
dépose nous déployons nos troupes sur
les frontières de l'alliance ce que ne
font pas tous nos alliés loin s'en faut
il ne saurait être question pour notre
part que le temps deviennent le
supplétif du pacte caucus où le rempart
d'un quad qui a proclamé son caractère
non militaire ce mini s'il faut que
l'alliance soit concentrée sur la
sécurité euro-atlantique et vous nous
donnez vous nous direz comment vous
oeuvrez et comment le gouvernement va
oeuvrer pour que le nouveau concept
stratégique de l'otan correspondent bien
à cet impératif enfin la vente de sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire change
totalement la donne dans la dos
pacifique sans aucune concertation
préalable entre alliés est-ce que c'est
seulement conforme au traité de non
prolifération nucléaire
beaucoup s'interrogent vous le savez sur
ce sujet n'est-il pas grave et dangereux
de mettre en oeuvre un tel
bouleversement stratégie et là vous nous
direz quel est votre notre marge de
manoeuvre dans cette situation nouvelle
alors il ya une conversation entreprises
dans la république et le président
américain elle a marqué mais l'apparence
de début d'apaisement à quelles
conditions est ce qu'on a obtenu
un certain nombre d'éléments que nous
souhaitions certains disent d'ores et
déjà que nous nous sommes apaisés bien
rapidement en quoi de votre point de vue
la société la situation s'est améliorée
depuis cet échange téléphonie la france
je le rappelle est une nation de l'inde
au pacifique avec près de deux millions
d'habitants 7000 militaires français
déployés de façon permanente et
possédant la deuxième plus grande zone
d'exclusivité économie du monde nous
sommes donc partie prenante à part
entière en témoignent nos troupes pré
positionné nos actions chaque année pour
la liberté de navigation nos efforts
pour doter l'union d'une stratégie indo
pacifique
ils restent nos alliés australien
s'inquiétaient de l'évolution de la
nouvelle calédonie et du risque d'un
éventuel désengagement français j'attire
votre attention sur ce point car des
informations concordantes nous
reviennent y compris d'australie 10 ans
mais comment voulez-vous nous appuyer
sur un allié qui laisse peut-être fils
et la nouvelle calédonie sans
véritablement se battre pour convaincre
des enjeux c'est en tous les cas des
échos qui nous remontent or les chances
du 12 décembre approche à grands pas
elle nous concerne tous du reste y
compris les parlementaires pour voir ce
que l'on peut faire dans cette
perspective donc vous le voyez monsieur
le ministre les questions sont
nombreuses notre commission entend les
creuser nous initions ce soir avec vous
même dans une audition ouverte à vos
collègues qui l'ont souhaité une série
d'auditions de haut niveau pour faire la
lumière sur les conditions qui ont
permis cette crise et donc sur les
conséquences tant sur l'inde au
pacifique et cette priorité comme au
sein de l'otan et nous souhaitons
pouvoir bien évidemment apprécié
l'action de notre outil diplomatique de
nos services de renseignement
et peut-être réévalué aussi nos
partenariats il est il est possible
monsieur le ministre puisque le bureau
de la commission s'est réunie ce matin
il est possible qu'au terme de ces
différentes
entretien la commission comme l'a
autorisé la conférence des présidents se
transforme en commission denquête non
pas pour montrer du doigt tel ou tel
dysfonctionnement mais peut-être plus
largement et plus gravement pour
s'interroger sur l'avenir de la france
dans l'inde au pacifique qui pose
effectivement des questions si nous
perdons ses points d'appui que je viens
d'évoquer voilà pourquoi monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie d'avoir
répondu à cette invitation j'ai proposé
puisque cette audition est diffusé j'ai
proposé que votre intervention mais
aussi l'intervention des représentants
de chaque groupe puisse s'exprimer tant
la sphère et gravit conséquente et à
votre demande vos réponses le seront
aussi comme ça l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale et du succès
intéresse pour avoir des éléments
d'information précis que maintenant vous
nous avez vous allez nous donner je vous
donne la parole monsieur ministre
sénatrices et sénateurs à jouer d'abord
puisque nous en venons président qu'on
le vend on associer là devant vois
l'hommage national qui datait de rendus
au sergent maxime blasco qui a été tué
vendredi dernier au mali au cours d'une
opération de contre terrorisme
le courage et le sacrifice de ce soldat
de très grande valeur nous oblige et
rappelle si besoin en était ce qu'est
l'engagement de la france dans ce pays
mais je ne suis pas venu aujourd'hui
pour parler du sel si je suis disponible
pour en parler nos matches et nous
l'avons fait en séance et j'étais à vos
côtés tout à l'heure aux avait dit
allez je le dis comme ça je les constate
est aussi
je voudrais donc revenir sur
les
sur des observations à la suite de votre
demande et à la suite de la rupture du
contrat fsp
d'abord
avant de revenir en détail sur les
enjeux de la crise diplomatique et sur
les initiatives que nous allons prendre
avec nos différents partenaires pourront
en tirer toutes les conséquences
j'aimerais commencer par rappeler un
certain nombre de faits ça me paraît
d'autant plus important que les derniers
jours ont été émaillées de déclarations
diverses de commentaires parfois très
approximatifs
en descendent 2016 en temps communistes
de la défense j'ai signé un accord
intergouvernemental
décembre 2016 avec le premier ministre
australien dale orr monsieur turnball
cet accord google intergouvernementale
posait le cadre d'une coopération
destiné à assister l'australie dans la
création de sa propre industrie navale
cet accord est entré en vigueur en 2017
il avait été conclu pour une période
initiale de 30 ans renouvelable
l'australie demandait une version
conventionnelle de nos sous marins à
propulsion nucléaire
et avait retenu l'offre de la société
navale groupe qui s'est engagé un
contenu australien des futurs
sous-marins de 60% je rappelle
qu'il y avait eu un appel d'offres que
la demande du président hollande nous
étions engagés
fortement sur
cet appel d'offres et qui opposait
différents constructeurs différents
acteurs
allemands japonais suédois
et nous avons donné la compétition alors
qu'au point de départ s'explique
d'ailleurs peut-être un certain nombre
de considérations postérieur tout le
monde considérait que nous n'avions
aucune chance
nous sommes battus et nous avons
remporté ce contrat
au total 12 sous marins de classe
attaque devait être construit plusieurs
centaines d'ingénieurs et de personnel
australien devait être formé dans le
cadre d'un vaste transfert de
compétences et de nombreuses
coopérations ont été mis en place à
cette fin la construction devait débuter
en 2023 pour une première mise à l'eau
prévue au début de la décennie 2030
autour de 2033 2034 pour la première
production ce type de projet je le
rappelle s'inscrit en effet toujours
dans le temps long
j'ajoute que ce programme avait vocation
à se dérouler dans le cadre d'un
partenariat industriel franco américain
l'entreprise française navale groupe est
de 7 ans associé avec l'industriel
américain lockheed martin chargé du
système de combat du sous marin
il s'agissait donc dès le départ d'une
forme de partenariat industriel avec les
états unis qui venait appuyer le
partenariat stratégique bilatéral franco
australien nous avons donc entretenu
depuis 2016 des contacts réguliers au
niveau politique avec les américains sur
ce sujet
on février 2019
madame la ministre des armées s'est
rendu à canberra à l'invitation de son
homologue christophe payne pour assister
à la signature du contrat cadre
stratégique par dave agreements entre
spa entre la navale groupe et
l'australie et en novembre 2019 je me
suis moi même rendu en australie
notamment adélaïde pour suivre de près
l'évolution du programme en lien
d'ailleurs avec mon homologue
australienne mary spain qui était en
2016 ministre de la défense qui était
devenu ministre affaires étrangères dans
qu'elle connaissait aussi très bien le
dossier puisque j'ai eu avec elle aussi
de très nombreux contacts réguliers
cours de ces dernières années
depuis lors nous avons mis en oeuvre la
première phase du programme d fsp à la
satisfaction de notre partenaire
australien
comme tous les programmes industriels
d'une ampleur telle que celui des fsp
des défis ont été rencontrés ils ont été
accentuées pendant l'année 2020 par
l'impact de la pandémie de lakovic 19
mai ces défis ont été
systématiquement surmonté par
l'engagement des autorités politiques
françaises et par celui de notre
industriel et si bien surmontée que
navale groupe recevait voudrait bien
voulu le rappeler monsieur le président
combes on recevait le 15 septembre c'est
à dire le jour même de l'annoncé
trilatérale la confirmation de la
satisfation de la satisfaction de la
revue stratégique des autorités
australiennes
ouvrant la possibilité d'une signature
rapide du contrat pour la deuxième phase
puis ce qu'il a fait c'est un contrat
gigogne que un contrat-cadre et
différents contrats qui se succèdent ce
qui est logique pour une programme d'une
telle durée ouvrant la possibilité une
scène y était rapide du contrat pour la
deuxième phase du programme fsp qui
avait été négocié ce contrat deuxième
phase au cours de l'été
à compter de la rencontre du président
de la république avec le premier
australien à paris le 15 juin dernier
nous étions rentrés dans une nouvelle
phase de dialogue avec l'australie
puisque
à cette occasion puis lors des échanges
que nous avons eus à mon niveau et à
celui de la ministre des armées les
australiens sans contesté le déroulement
satisfaisant du projet sur le plan
industriel
et en reconnaissant même officiellement
et publiquement
la presse que le programme fsp était
bien mis sur les rails le 16 juin ils
ont fait part voir cet entretien du
premier morrison de l'évolution de leur
analyse du contexte stratégique
asiatique en lien avec la croissance des
tensions avec la chine ils ont indiqué
s'interroger sur l'impact de cette
analyse évolutif sur les besoins de
leurs forces armées mais sans remettre
en cause le programme d'une part et sans
soulever la question du mode de
propulsion d'autre part ni sans
mentionner un projet quelconque d'accord
tripartite
je précise d'ailleurs que j'ai reçu
anthony blinken secret tata de
secrétaire d'état américain au quai
d'orsay le 25 juin dernier je lui ai
rappelé notre coopération industrielle
sur ce programme je lui ai rappelé aussi
les principes de notre position sur la
nécessité de défendre un espace indo
pacifique libre et ouvert et j'ai cité
l'exemple de la coopération que nous
avions dans le domaine des sous-marins
avec l'australie et il m'a dit partager
je le cite le constat de la nécessité
d'une approche commune et de la capacité
de nos démocraties à être plus forte
ensemble quelques jours plus tard madame
la mise et armé s'est rendu à washington
et son homologue a souligné la nécessité
et le besoin d'un partenariat renforcé
pour travailler en équipe et pour être
plus forts ensemble je le cite
le 30 août
à l'issue d'une réunion ministérielle
franco australienne en format de +2 nous
avions créé ce dispositif de format 2 +
2 dans le cadre du programme infiniti
c'est un programme sur lequel je
reviendrai peut-être dans la discussion
que nous avions engagés qui cadre d'un
partenariat stratégique global dans
lequel il ya des déclinaisons sur
différents différents points et il avait
été décidé dans la phase 2 du programme
infiniti que nous aurions régulièrement
des réunions ministérielles
ministre de la défense ni affaires
étrangères
que nous préservons jusqu'à présent
quelques
relations particulières c'est le cadeau
du japon et c'était il fut un temps le
cas de la russie
donc ces deux réunions qui associe les
mises affaires étrangères et les mises
de la défense de deux pays a permis le
30 août une déclaration conjointe et qui
a dans la suite logique de
ce que nous avons évoqué que ce que j'ai
évoqués il ya un instant a dit ceci je
cite cette déclaration commune des
quatre ministres les deux parties se
sont engagés à approfondir la
coopération dans le domaine des
industries de défense et améliorer leurs
capacités de pointe dans la région et
les ministres ont souligné l'importance
du fsp
c'était le 30 août
c'est au niveau ministériel et c'est une
déclaration commune
c'est à dire quinze jours avant le cas
cet homme je rappelle que le 15
septembre le ministre de la défense
australien fait savoir que nous étions
prêts passer à la phase suivante du
programme fsp le même jour qu'un sept
ans
donc je le dis de manière catégorique à
aucun moment avant le 15 septembre
les australiens ne nous ont ouvertement
exprimé leur souhait d'abandonner le
programme de sous marins de classe
attaque ni de mettre un terme à notre
partenariat au profit du pacte
tripartite annoncé
les australiens n'ont pas non plus
exprimé le besoin de recourir à la
technologie de la propulsion nucléaire
alors que nous les avions interrogé
spécifiquement sur leurs réflexions
possibles sur le recours une telle
option les australiens n'ont pas répondu
ni exprimé de besoins à ce sujet
et il va sans dire que les australiens
n'ont absolument jamais fait état de
discussions engagées avec d'autres
partenaires que la france
d'où notre stupeur et notre
consternation lorsque dans l'après-midi
du 15 septembre dernier c'est à dire
quelques heures avant que cette décision
ne soit rendue publique par le président
biden et le premier morrison la france a
été prévenu de la fin du programme par
une lettre adressée au président de la
république par le premier morrison et
par deux appels téléphoniques que nous
avons reçu florence parly et moi même
avec nos homologues australiens
ni les américains ni les britanniques
n'ont pris l'initiative d'une
information des autorités françaises
je rajoute que nous avons pris
l'initiative de soulever auprès de nos
partenaires américains à très haut
niveau politique l'importance que nous
attachons à ce partenariat stratégique
qui était un partenariat
franco-américain avec l'australie compte
tenu du rôle joué par lockheed martin et
nous recevions que de réponses
dilatoires nous allons regarder ou de
réponse trop peu c'est une question
bilatérale franco australienne nous
avons même chercher à nouveau quelques
jours avant la réunion dite de plus de
américano australienne à reprendre
contact avec nos homologues américains
mais sans succès à quelques heures de
l'annoncé alerté par des fuites dans les
journaux nous avons sollicité les
autorités américaines sur la véracité
des faits allégués par la presse les
américaines aux interlocuteurs
américains ont à ce moment là seulement
confirmer ces informations
et après des mois de trot prix et de
faux semblants et malgré une
mobilisation constante de notre part
voilà les faits ils sont éloquents et si
je peux dire ils parlent d'eux mêmes
ce qui est dangereux
maintenant je veux parler des enjeux ce
qui est en jeu dans ce qu'il faut bien
qualifier de trahison vous dites
camoufler mois que les trahisons
ce qu'il faut bien qualifier de trahison
de notre partenariat stratégique avec
l'australie de rupture de confiance dans
la relation transatlantique et de
confirmation du spectaculaire degré de
dépendance à l'égard des états unis de
l'australie et du royaume uni
ce n'est pas seulement les intérêts
industriels de la france attirer je vais
d'ailleurs le redire avec vous devant
vous avec force que une poêle y revenir
mais si vous avez des auditions qui vous
permettront de clarifier aussi ce point
que nous défendrons par tous les moyens
légaux car ils sont évidemment prévus
par les textes qui nous lie aux
australiens pour information nous
n'avons pas pour l'instant de
dénonciation de l'accord
intergouvernemental
il ya simplement une rupture de contrat
entre avec naval groupe mais il n'y a
pas
de rupture
officielle de l'accord
intergouvernemental qui prévoit
d'ailleurs des dispositions spécifiques
dans ce cas
l'enjeu c'est aussi la place d'aidé
européen dans le monde d'aujourd'hui et
cet enjeu est double
c'est d'abord le sens de nos alliances
ndo partenariat un tel comportement
n'est en effet tout simplement pas
acceptables ni de la part de nos
partenaires australiens
avait claqué avec lesquels nous avions
approfondi notre partenaire stratégique
et à l'ecoute desquelles nous avons
toujours été ni de la part de notre
allié américain car nous pensions que
nous pouvions reprendre une logique de
coordination confiante j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'exprimer publiquement et en
français et aux états unis sur ce sujet
donc je ne m'y attarde pas
l'enjeu pour les européens c'est aussi
et ce n'est pas moins fondamentale la
manière dont nous choisissons de
répondre en fonction nous intérêt propre
et de notre lecture commune de la
situation aux tensions et aux menaces
qui existent aujourd'hui en particulier
dans la zone indo pacifique vous il est
fait référence monsieur le président
dans vos propos introductif
locus est en fait le nom d'une alliance
militaire nouvelle
et d'un alignement sur une logique qui
systématisent la confrontation
voire la confrontation militaire
logique qui aux états unis
c'est mis progressivement en place
depuis l'administration obama
alignement nouveau dans le cadre de
l'australie et du reste tout à fait en
rupture avec la volonté de souveraineté
qui fondait le choix du premier ministre
en vol je rappelle que le premier stand
le premier ministre mauricien font
partie de la même formation politique
il y aura un effet beaucoup à dire à la
fois sur l'abandon de souveraineté que
représente le renoncement au programme
attaque et sur le saut dans l'inconnu
que constitue pour les australiens
je dis vraiment saut dans l'inconnu que
constitue pour les australiens le choix
de recourir à une technologie qui ne
maîtrisent pas qu'ils ne maîtriseront
pas l'avenir et qu'il aimait donc
entièrement à la merci des évolutions de
la politique américaine
alignement donc nouveau de la part de
l'australie mais alignement en revanche
parfaitement prévisible mais toujours
décevant dans le cas du royaume uni dont
on ne voit toujours pas très bien quel
rôle il jouera dans ce projet
cette voie ce n'est pas la voie choisie
par la france et par l'union européenne
qui je le rappelle publiait sa propre
stratégie pour l'inde au pacifique le
jour même où l'accord américano
australien a été rendue publique
pour assumer pleinement la compétition
avec la chine et on a déjà parlé ici
dont nous voyons bien la montée en
puissance militaire dont nous voyons
bien l'agressivité croissante les visées
hégémoniques
y compris au besoin par des moyens
militaires nous voulons pour notre part
travailler à construire avec l'ensemble
des acteurs et des pays l'inde au
pacifique un modèle alternatif au modèle
chinois qui respecte pleinement la
souveraineté des pays de l'inde au
pacifique il s'agit contrer la stratégie
de la chine qui est souvent un
multilatéralisme de façade et qui
consiste pour cette puissance à prendre
chacun des états de la zone au piège
d'un face-à-face asymétrique
et afin de mouvoir le multilatéralisme
que nous estimons nécessaire à la
stabilité de l'indonésie fiq nous
entendons aider à desserrer l'étau et
montrer dans tous les domaines la
sécurité le commerce la connectivité la
protection de l'environnement la liberté
de navigation la conformité au droit
international qu'une autre voie est
possible
une voix respectueuse des souverainetés
nationales une voix conforme au droit
international et 40 de la liberté de
circulation en mer une voix qui tout en
assumant pleinement le jeu du rapport de
force y compris militaires ne fasse pas
en revanche le jeu des tensions et de la
confiture alité et parce qu'elle est
elle même une nation de l'ado pacifique
vous l'avez aussi rappelé tout à l'heure
avec des territoires dans les deux
océans près de deux millions de
ressortissants dans cet espace une
présence militaire permanente de 7000
pas mes femmes la france a été le fer de
lance de cette stratégie alternative qui
est désormais une stratégie européenne
comme le montre qui est déjà fait
référence la communication conjointe sur
la stratégie de l'union européenne pour
la coopération dans la région indo
pacifique et qui planifient des actions
concrètes pour renforcer notre
engagement stratégique à l'égard de
cette région
voilà les enjeux je voudrais évoquer les
conséquences
pour marquer la gravité de cette
trahison
et de cette rupture de confiance nous
avons vous le savez pris la décision de
rappeler nos ambassadeurs en australie
et aux etats unis
les consultations que nous avons menées
ces derniers jours avec nos ambassadeurs
nous ont permis de clarifier les
conséquences stratégiques de cette crise
et de préciser les initiatives que nous
prendrons pour y répondre
conséquence d'abord dans la relation
transatlantique
le présent de la république et le
présent baden se sont entretenus par
téléphone mercredi dernier et j'ai eu à
la suite de cet entretien à new york une
longue conversation en tête à tête avec
le secrétaire d'état en tony blinken en
marge de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies
des premiers engagements ont été pris
par les états unis notamment sur trois
sujets importants
la reconnaissance par ces derniers de la
nécessité d'une défense européenne plus
forte et plus performante
la reconnaissance de l'importance
stratégique de l'engagement de la france
et de l'union européenne la zone indo
pacifique
le renforcement de l'appui des états
unis aux opérations antiterroristes
conduit par les états européens en
particulier dans la région du sahel
et ces trois sujets vont faire l'objet
de consultations approfondies avec nos
interlocuteurs américains
elles vont être conduites dans la
perspective d'un nouvel entretien que
nos deux présidents auront dans au
courant du mode la fin du mois d'octobre
pour
dans une pour une éventuelle rencontre
en europe et nous allons assurer ce
suivi là
le secteur des draps blinken et moi même
de manière extrêmement précise mais ce
que je peux vous dire à ce stade c'est
que la crise que nous connaissons est
grave qu'elle n'est pas achevée
simplement parce que le dialogue est
renoué
qu'elle va durer et quand sortir
requerra des actes forts plutôt que des
paroles
je note d'ailleurs que ce constat que je
fais devant vous c'est le constat qu'a
fait publiquement mon homologue
américain à la sortie de l'entretien que
j'avais eue avec lui
s'agissant de l'australie
une telle rupture de confiance appelle
un examen et une remise à plat de nos
coopérations
les consultations que nous menons
actuellement avec notre ambassadeur qui
lui n'est pas rentré
notre ambassadeur aux états unis rendent
ce soit notre ambassadeur en australie
rentrera mais pour l'instant nous
poursuivons avec lui des consultations
qui nous permettront de clarifier
l'évolution que nous souhaitons donner à
notre relation bilatérale
que nous allons entièrement passé en
revue la lumière de ce choix qui est
celui d'une intégration complète dans
l'outil de défense américain c'est à
dire d'une perte totale de souveraineté
en effet gelé dit tout à l'heure le
programme des sous-marins s'inscrivait
dans un partenaire stratégique beaucoup
plus large avec l'australie partenariat
affinity australie france initiative en
référence aussi à notre proximité cédé
par la convergence de nos intérêts
stratégiques
nous venions de nous engager je les dis
dans une deuxième phase de cette
initiative le fait que l'annoncent du
pacte tripartite soit intervenue le jour
de la diffusion de la stratégie
européenne pour l'asie pacifique est
révélatrice de la distance qui s'est
ainsi créé entre l'australie et l'union
européenne
d'ailleurs nous le voyons très
clairement sur le sujet de la lutte
contre le changement climatique
est par exemple très clair pour nous que
alors qu'il y avait dans les programmes
affinity une dimension de l'ue de
partager contre le changement climatique
il est très clair pour nous que la
confirmation par le premier ministre
maurice own à quelques semaines
seulement de la coop 26 de choix
contraire à nos vues et à nous intéresse
sur le climat et le charbon alors que
même le président byden dans son
entretien lui avait demandé de faire un
geste supplémentaire pour en perspective
de la coupe 26
et qu'il a annoncé publiquement
rester sur la logique que du charbon
tout ça ne peut pas ne pas avoir de
conséquences sur les relations entre
l'union européenne et l'australie il est
donc indispensable de faire une revue
complète de notre relation
nous ne pouvons par ailleurs que
constater que le choix de l'australie et
se traduit par une perte totale de
souveraineté avec une intégration
complète dans l'outil de défense
américain n'avons pas fait le même choix
comme le rappelle notre premier objectif
de notre stratégie nationale pour l'inde
au pacifique qui est d'assurer de
défendre l'intégrité de la souveraineté
de la france la protection de ses
ressortissants de ces territoires et de
sa zone économique exclusive je signale
d'ailleurs
parlementaires présents se nomme nous
vous le savez déjà que 93 % de notre
zone économique exclusive se trouve dans
le pacifique
93% et on a la deuxième zone de
communiquer ce que dit du monde nous
avons fait le choix de renforcer notre
partenariat
dans la région ados pacifique qui est
aussi notre géographie au moment où
l'australie elle semble privilégier
plutôt ses liens historiques
donc la remise à plat de nos
coopérations bilatérales n'aura pas
d'impact sur notre détermination à
rester pleinement engagé dans la région
pacifique j'ai d'ailleurs dire à cet
instant que j'ai eu par ailleurs à new
york des entretiens fructueux important
avec mon collègue d'indiens mon collègue
indonésien et mon collègue japonais sur
l'ensemble de ces questions
quant aux britanniques la balle est
désormais dans leur camp
s'ils veulent que nous puissions aller
de l'avant et retrouver une forme de
confiance
c'est ce que le président républicain
dick est très fermement au premier
ministre boris johnson vendredi dernier
lors d'un entretien téléphonique
mais avant toute chose il faudra là
aussi passé en revue notre relation il
faudra que londres cesse de violer ses
engagements
stance sur le protocole de l'élan d'une
heure que sur la corde commerce et de
coopération c'est tout à fait
d'actualité aujourd'hui même ou encore
en matière migratoire
de notre côté nous sommes prêt s'il le
faut à utiliser tous les leviers dont
nous disposons
mais c'est sur les conséquences de cette
crise pour la france et pour les
européens que je voudrais surtout
insister
dans la dos pacifique
nous devons poursuivre et accélérer la
mise en oeuvre de stratégies propres ce
sera l'un des axes forts de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne au premier semestre
comme le dit très clairement le
président de la république le choix fait
par l'australie n'a pas d'impact sur
notre stratégie indo pacifique dans la
région
des bouillons avec plusieurs partenaires
depuis depuis longtemps et cela pour
deux raisons d'une part la france n'a
pas attendu de signer un contrat avec
l'australie pour avoir des intérêts à
défendre de l'inde au pacifique je vous
rappelle que nous sommes une nation de
l'inde au pacifique et d'autre part nous
ne pouvons tout simplement pas tourner
le dos à une région dont dépendra 60% du
pib mondial en 2030 et là où se joue
aussi nos intérêts
européens nous aurons d'ailleurs à cet
égard une réunion au niveau ministériel
que nous organiserons sur l'anneau
passive et avec nos partenaires d'asie
pacifique au courant de la présidence
française
nos efforts de la france et des
européens au côté nos partenaires clés
de la région donc vocation à s'inscrire
dans la durée
plus généralement
nous devons prendre en compte cette
décision américains ainsi que ce qui
vient de se passer en afghanistan et les
conséquences que cela emporte pour notre
sécurité je pense au risque de
résurgence du terrorisme dans la
réflexion stratégique européenne qui
aboutira également sous présidence
française à l'adoption de notre boussole
stratégique ce document constituera en
quelque sorte le premier livre blanc de
la défense et la sécurité européenne
dise où nous avons la charge de la faire
aboutir nous la france
si l'europe doit impérativement aller au
bout de cette réflexion stratégique
c'est parce que le recentrement de notre
allié américain
initié il ya déjà dix ans sur une
définition plus ciblée de ses intérêts
fondamentaux nous met en demeure de nous
donner les moyens d'agir de manière
autonome lorsque nos intérêts de
sécurité sont engagées ou lorsque les
valeurs auxquelles nous croyons sont en
jeu faute de quoi pour parler très
clairement nous place sur yon nous mêmes
dans une position de vulnérabilité et
d'impuissance
c'est une question dont j'ai bien sûr
parlé avec mes homologues des 27 la
semaine dernière dès mon arrivée à new
york puisque nous avons tenu dès le
lundi de la semaine dernière
une réunion des 27 qui avait été dominée
par ce sujet j'ai pu constater avec
intérêt que il comprenait parfaitement
que cette crise est que ce n'était pas
d'abord des considérations de soutien
amicale qui exprimait à l'égard de la
france mais qu'il y avait bien un enjeu
européen qu'il y avait bien une crise
stratégiques européennes ils l'ont
d'ailleurs dit publiquement puisque je
vous renvoie aux déclarations qui ont
été faites à ce sujet par le haut
représentant
josep borrell par la présidente de la
commission madame dhalla yen et par le
président charles michel je vous renvoie
aussi aux déclarations dahico masse et
d'autres ministres européens présents à
new york y ait qu ils l'ont déclaré au
cours de la cours de la semaine à
différents moments
dans le cadre de cette future boussole
stratégique nous travaillons donc à une
approche proprement européenne des
menaces qui pèsent sur nous aujourd'hui
nous travaillons à renforcer nos
capacités opérationnelles et industriels
à établir des priorités claires en matin
de partenariats en particulier dans
l'anneau pacifique nous aussi en afrique
et à défendre nos intérêts et notre
liberté d'action dans ce qu'on appelle
les espaces contesté c'est à dire les
mers et les océans d'une part l'espace
exo atmosphérique d'autre part et bien
sûr le cyberespace et l'espace
informationnel il est donc urgent de
renforcer encore par l'europe de la
défense que nous construisons pas à pas
de façon concrète et et pragmatique
depuis maintenant plusieurs années il y
va de notre sécurité et de notre
souveraineté
à mon sens il y va aussi de l'avenir de
l'alliance atlantique et je crois qu'on
aurait tort d'y voir un paradoxe
car nous savions bien
qu'avant la crise acte que la crise
actuelle n'éclate que l'avenir de notre
alliance passe par son rééquilibrage et
par la refondation des liens entre les
états unis et leurs oeufs et les
européennes et celles donc pas de sortir
de l'alliance atlantique mais lors du
dernier sommet de l'otan le 14 juin nous
avons engagé une revue du concept
stratégique de l'alliance cette
problématique sera au coeur de débats
qui s'ouvrent et que nous allons voir
dans les mois qui viennent dans la
perspective du prochain sommet qui aura
lieu à madrid en 2022 et le traitement à
l'otan des enjeux l'un d'eux pacifique
devra bien sûr être discuté dans ce
contexte
mais dans le contexte politique actuel
il ne me semble pas inutile de rappeler
que le coeur de métier si je puis dire
de l'alliance atlantique c'est notre
défense collective garanti par l'article
5 qui reste pleinement valable
les etats unis jouent un rôle essentiel
et la crise que nous traversons ne
remets pas en cause cette mission
centrale de l'otan et nous ne voyons pas
non plus l'opportunité bien au contraire
de réduire le rôle joué par la france
dans cette mission de redéfinition
fondamental que nous avons mis sur
l'établi pour aboutir à un concept
stratégique refonder pour le prochain
sommet de 2022 voilà quelques mots sur
les faits que je tenais à rappeler sur
les enjeux que je tenais à pointer et
sur un certain nombre de conséquences
que je tenais à évoquer pour lancer nous
échanges au sujet de cette crise
diplomatique qui à mon sens ce doit être
un aiguillon de souveraineté pour les
européens c'est ainsi que nous
l'entendons et c'est ainsi que l'entente
je crois nos partenaires des 27 après
les différentes réunions que nous avons
pu avoir à new york la semaine dernière
sur ce sujet
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
éclaircissements sans plus attendre donc
comme
chaque groupe représenté ici au sein de
la commission va pouvoir s'exprimer par
l'intermédiaire d'un de ses
représentants et donc pour le groupe et
l'air la parole et à cédric perrin
de jeu merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je ministre
conformément à la décision prise lors de
la conférence des présidents la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense et des forces armées vous
auditionne dans un format adapté au
sujet de la défense des intérêts
stratégiques de l'état nous espérons
évidemment de votre part des réponses
sincères mais surtout
des nuées d'éléments que nous aurions
déjà lu dans la presse
par votre passé et votre expérience
d'élu local à lorient plus de ministres
la défense monsieur le ministre vous
maîtrisez parfaitement le volet
industriel du dossier
de la création de dcns à celle de naval
groupe
outre le volet commercial de cette
affaire qui nous invite collectivement à
une réflexion sur au plus large sur la
gestion des champions industriels de
défense et de la team française à
l'export la préoccupation de mon groupe
au sénat et le maintien de la france au
rang de puissance militaire et
diplomatique et la préservation
évidemment de ses intérêts la perte de
ce contrat fragilise notre crédibilité
internationale la perte est certes
économique mais elle est avant tout
stratégique et diplomatique
monsieur le ministre dans une zone
marquée par le pivot américain en asie
pacifique depuis 2008 et face à la
montée en puissance chinoise que
personne n'ignore évidemment on le voit
bien en nouvelle calédonie pensez vous
que la politique diplomatique française
a suffisamment démontré sa volonté de
présence dans cette zone
ne pensez-vous pas que l'absence d'un
engagement ferme de l'exécutif en faveur
d'une nouvelle calédonie française a
largement contribué à envoyer des
signaux de désengagement de l'état
français à nos partenaires australiens
qui profondément inquiet auront préféré
un alliés anglo saxons à une solution
américaine est une solution américaine
pardon démontrant tout refus de
déclassement stratégique finalement
monsieur le ministre avons-nous
suffisamment démontré à nos alliés
australien que nous avons dans le
pacifique les moyens de nos ambitions
telle est la vraie question merci
beaucoup
merci cédric pour le groupe socialiste
écologique et républicains la parole est
à jean marc todeschini
monsieur le ministre il n'est pas
courant que je prenne la parole lorsque
la commission auditionne j'étais en
effet votre secrétaire d'état vous aviez
l'habitude de me dire votre secrétaire
d'état préférées et effectivement nous
avons vécu des choses ensemble et
aujourd'hui je ne peux que me souvenir
de ce 25 avril 2016 lorsque nous étions
conjointement avec
gouverneur général d'australie
à vider le bretonneux dans la somme pour
commémorer de l'anzac day et avec tous
nos amis australiens c'est lors du
retour que nous avons appris que vous
avez appris aussi que le l'elysée nous
informer que le premier ministre
australien et fait savoir que c'était de
le contrat proposé par la france qui
était retenu nous allons cela en commun
c'était le marché du siècle à l'époque
dans les commentaires vous aviez payer
d'autres personnes plusieurs
déplacements d'australie et moi même j'y
suis allé donc je sais que les efforts
que vous avez pu faire et aujourd'hui
alors permettez moi tout d'abord
question toute simple
conflit n'ont pas fait le gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez aujourd'hui où la
ministre qui vous a succédé
c'est un sujet en effet tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que l'afrique d'autres
pays est ici face à un échec
considérable et un échec diplomatique
rares je ne reprendrai que les
déclarations des analyses de loïc de la
mornais journalistes de france
télévision aux états unis qui constitue
nous dit que et qui dit que le jus des
états unis la france un enfant il roule
par terre mais qu'elle va bientôt
rentrer dans le rang parce qu'elle reste
un petit pays vu de chez eux c'est pour
cette raison nous continuons à réclamer
avec le groupe socialiste la
constitution d'une commission denquête
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui au sein de
cette commission la majorité est
favorable à une commission d'enquêté
comme ils sont en quête qui ne vont pas
être dirigée contre tel ou tel autre tel
ou tel responsable politique mais elle
doit justement nous permettre de définir
des dysfonctionnements qui ont pu
conduire à un des plus grands échecs
commerciaux d'histoire de notre
industrie de défense et un recul sans
précédent sur la scène internationale de
notre pays il s'agit là d'une exigence
démocratique et nous entendons faire de
ce travail de contrôle et non pas n'ont
pas peur
que ce travail de contrôle se fasse
normalement dans le cadre de notre
travail de parlementaire et nous ne
voulons pas en aucun cas nous érigée en
procureur contrairement à ce que l'une
de vos collègues a pu répondre en
parlons ici au sénat lors des questions
d'actualité à mon ami rachid des mâles
nous d'entendre jeter la pierre à
quiconque mais pour nous les
interrogations sont nombreuses monsieur
le ministre la ligne médiatique portée
par le gouvernement depuis l'annnonce de
la décision australienne
consiste à faire porter l'entière
responsabilité sur les autorités
australiennes et américaines si l'on
suit cette logique personnes dans les
services où le gouvernement n'a été
informé de près ou de loin de ce qui
allait arriver nous souhaitons être sûr
de bien comprendre la communication du
gouvernement je parle bien du
gouvernement car nous n'avons
bizarrement que très peu entendu le
président de la république sur ce sujet
quels étaient les informations exactes
qu'avait le gouvernement français tout
au long de ces derniers mois quant au
déroulement de ce contrat le dirigeant
de laval groupe notre poste à canberra
les services de renseignement ou tout
autre acteur de ce dossier avec il fait
part à certains moments
d'éventuelles difficultés ou de tout
élément qui aurait pu alerter le
gouvernement
au-delà du constat et desrosiers
formulée par votre intermédiaire et vous
avez tenu des propos assez fort dès le
départ sur en réaction peut-on
réellement se contenter de ce communiqué
comme suit en entretien téléphonique
entre le président macron et son
homologue américain peut-on se
satisfaire même si ceux ci rejoigne un
voeu pieux qui est celui de ré affirmer
simplement réaffirmé jeudi bien
l'importance d'une défense européenne
complémentaire de l'otan n'est ce pas
faire preuve d'angélisme ou
d'amateurisme surtout que dès le
lendemain de cet entretien téléphonique
le président biden prenez l'initiative
de raviver le quad une autre alliance
pour contrer la chine notre pays restant
là aussi pour le moment sur le bord du
chemin enfin pour conclure peut-on
croire à une stratégie européenne pour
la coopération dans la région à nos
pacifique croyez vous réellement vous
même monsieur le ministre à volonté de
nos partenaires européens de porter haut
et fort la question de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne
ne surestimons nous pas notre influence
et notre attractivité par rapport aux
états unis pour nos partenaires
européens merci
triste olivier cadic
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je veux tout d'abord pour
remercier pour votre propos introductif
et nous parlons ici d'un échec mais cet
échec ne doit pas masquer aussi tous nos
succès parce que nos succès en matière
d'exportation de l'industrie on a dans
l'industrie militaire peuvent aussi
expliquer une certaine nervosité de nos
concurrents alors les conditions de la
rupture du contrat des sous marins
australiens interroge en france mais pas
seulement comme l'a fait remarquer serge
thomann notre conseiller des français à
l'étranger pour l'australie trois
anciens premiers ministres australiens
ont fait part de leur indignation suite
à la décision de rompre ce contrat kevin
ruud paul keating et encore mal comme
tomtom ball ce matin même dans le
national press club ont ouvertement
critiqué la décision du gouvernement
morrison malcolm turnbull en particulier
a dénoncé la rupture du contrat avec
naval groupe mais surtout la manière
utilisée il a déploré cette rupture de
confiance et dénoncé un comportement
qualifié 2 je cite maladroit trompeur et
qui va coûter très cher il réfute que
son gouvernement est agi dans l'intérêt
national alors ma première question est
quel message souhaitez-vous envoyé à ses
trois anciens premiers ministres
australiens et à tous les citoyens
australiens qui ont déclaré regretter
cette décision
comme le disait le général de gaulle les
états n'ont pas d'amis ils n'ont que des
intérêts plusieurs rapports récents dont
2 issu du sénat confirme que la france
représente une menace majeure pour nos
pays démocratiques
pardon la chine pardonnez moi c'est
terrible
et merci d'avoir rectifié
pirates
piratage informatique des informations
propagande espionnage corruption et j'en
passe démontre que le pcc peine à faire
la différence entre une politique
d'influencé une politique d'ingérence la
chine développe sa marine militaire pour
en faire la plus importante du monde
rien qu'au niveau des capacités navales
elle a lancé l'équivalent en volume de
la flotte française dans l'espace de
quatre ans seulement l'objectif déclaré
du parti communiste chinois à l'horizon
2040 9 et notamment l'assujettissement
de taïwan par la propagande
l'intimidation ou l'invasion usage
éventuel envisager de la force par pékin
contre taïwan pourrait entraîner un
conflit généralisé à grande échelle
plusieurs voix se font entendre pour
regretter une présence trop discrète de
la france dans la zone indo pacifique ce
qui justifierait d'après ces voix la
décision australienne à la veille du
déplacement à taïwan de notre groupe
d'échangé d'études sénateur du sénat
présidée par alain richard quel message
la france veut-elle faire passer pour
réaffirmer notre présence dans l'un des
eaux pacifique et faire taire ses
critiques je vous remercie
merci olivier pour le rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
andré gattolin oui merci monsieur le
président messieurs le ministre merci
pour votre exposé moi la question de la
rupture
de l'accord sur les sous-marins me par
est pas simplement un sujet commercial
mais évidemment sujet comme vous l'avez
exprimé plusieurs fois proprement
géostratégique vous allez parler de
l'extraordinaire dépendance de
l'australie et du royaume uni aux états
unis et la question que je me pose un
moment nous nous entendons développer
une boussole stratégiques européennes
avec toute la complexité que cela ait
discuté à 27 états ne sommes nous pas en
face d'une nouvelle boussole
stratégiques américaines j'entends que
les choses ont évolué et qui est un
continuum depuis obama trump et joe
biden aujourd'hui mais que constate-t-on
dans un passé très récent outre cet
accord hocus soudain et rapprocher le
retrait en afghanistan
là
je vais dire normalisation des relations
avec la russie tout d'un coup les états
unis qui voulaient sanctionner toutes
les entreprises qui participent à la
construction de nord stream 2 pour
soutenir les amis ukrainiens ont décrété
que c'était plus un problème bref tout
apparaît comme si aujourd'hui les aider
des états unis de
poser nue situer console grand enjeu
stratégique
c'est celui de la montée en puissance de
la chine et de ses velléités extérieur
et faire de la question de taiwan et de
son possible envahissement la solde des
questions reléguant toutes les autres au
deuxième ou au troisième rang donc face
à ça de quelle arme dispose la france
peut-être à partir de l'europe la
boussole stratégiques européennes mais
on a en négociations déjà depuis
plusieurs années un traité de
libre-échange union européenne australie
on a évoqué les troubles que cette
rupture de contrat et cette nouvelle
alliance créée pensez vous monsieur le
ministre est sincèrement que l'union
européenne qui est en charge notamment
la commission en charge des négociations
de pour ce traité de libre échange est
prête à agir et soutenir totalement la
france dans une position je dirais un
petit peu forte vis-à-vis de l'australie
où est ce que les choses continueront
comme toujours avec la lenteur et la
volonté systématique de conclure un
nouvel accord commercial choix merci
merci andré pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes sa
parole est à pierre laurent
bien merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
propos liminaire
vous venez de répéter il y avait déjà eu
beaucoup de déclarations ce sens des
mots qui confirme que l' affaire est
grave ou la mélodie vous même vous avez
insisté sur les mots de trahison de
rupture de confiance
il est donc évident que après avoir
employé de tellement
la sphère ne peut pas être sans
conséquence sans conséquences majeures
sur
les question du sens de
nos alliances
et c'est sur cette question que
je veux préciser ma question
vous venez de dire peut-être d'une
manière plus claire que je ne vous
l'avais entendu jusqu'ici dire que il y
a deux concepts opposés sur la stratégie
indo pacifique
celui que la france défend et qu'elle
aurait fait accepter par les européens
et celui des américains vous avez même
dit que la nouvelle alliance militaire
poussé par les américains de
systématiser la confrontation et vous a
dit ça n'est pas l'orientation que nous
souhaitons dans l'inde au pacifique il
ya donc un débat qui n'est pas un débat
mineurs entre alliés sur sur cette
question donc ma
mon interpellation est la suivante
comment allez-vous continuer à tirer les
conséquences de cette situation
ah vous avez évoqué la question de
l'otan où vous savez que c'est une
question que je pose régulièrement que
j'ai reposé la semaine dernière dans la
question d'actualité que j'ai adressé à
ministre de la défense à vous dit et
vous re dit encore aujourd'hui nous
n'allons pas quitter l'alliance mais à
quoi sert de répéter ça tant que nous
n'avons pas poussée au bout la revue
stratégique
de l'alliance parce que les propos que
vous venez de tenir montre que les
débats stratégiques
traverse l'alliance de manière assez
sérieuse et peuvent mettre en cause
nos intérêts et ceux des européens
donc ma question est la suivante est ce
que nous n'allons pas assister à une
nouvelle occasion manquée je me rappelle
du débat sur la mort cérébrale de l'otan
là aussi des mots très forts
et puis ensuite
peu de conséquences d'une déclaration
pourtant extrêmement forte
donc comment allez-vous agir pour ne pas
une nouvelle fois manqué l'occasion de
procéder à cette revue stratégique
sérieuse et au fond de nos alliances et
deux petits ajouts
je voulais une précision vous avez
rappelé la chronologie des faits
est ce que ce débat je ne parle pas de
la rupture du contrat parce que j'ai
bien compris que ça n'avait pas été
explicitement évoqué avant mais est ce
que ce débat a eu lieu au g7 ou mois de
juin
dernier et en quels termes
c'est à dire est ce que nous disposons
réellement des éléments de discussion
stratégique
qui ont lieu en ce moment dans ce type
de sommet parce que on assiste à l'issue
des g7 à des déclarations
marquées assez globalement par
l'autosatisfaction sur nos alliances et
peu transparente sur les débats qui
traversent et ses sommets et puis
dernier ajout
vous n'avez pas évoqué la question qui a
été évoqué dans le propos liminaire
du président sur les enjeux de notre
libération
suite au choix de la propulsion
nucléaire pour l'accord sur les sous
marins australiens avec les états unis
c'est une question tout le monde se pose
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
décision stratégique des américains
merci
merci pierre pour le rassemblement
démocratique et social européen andré
guiol
merci président le seul ministre et
chers collègues comme vous l'avez
clairement exprimé monsieur le ministre
la rupture sans préavis du contrat de
vente des sous marins à l'australie est
ressenti comme une véritable trahison le
groupe rdse partage ce sentiment
compte tenu des éléments que vous avez
pu apporter ainsi que ceux exposés
publiquement par balle à la ministre
désormais il est clair que les états
unis les australiens ont fait preuve de
duplicité une attitude qui devrait nous
inviter à l'avenir rester sur nos gardes
à ce propos si je puis me permettre une
observation s'agissant du devoir de
vigilance ne serait-il pas plus utile de
s'interroger sur la nécessité de mieux
associer le parlement français sur les
ventes d'armes comme cela se pratique
dans d'autres pays différents rapports
parlementaires ont recommandé la
création d'une délégation parlementaire
au contrôle des armements si celle ci
avait existé plaçant le parlement dans
la boucle de la vente des sous marins
australiens 1 détection des signaux
faibles auraient-elles pu être facilitée
mais nous n'ignorons pas la sensibilité
de ce domaine
je souhaite également attirer votre
attention sur un autre point du côté
australien il ya manifestement eu un
changement de besoin scellée par le
partenariat au cul soul avait dit que
nous n'avons pas évidence anticipée
alors même que les rapports se tendent
dans la région indo pacifique caméra
privilégie finalement l'acquisition de
sous marins à propulsion nucléaire des
engins plus offensif alors que les
sous-marins à propulsion conventionnelle
district et diesel électrique d'une
discrétion acoustique plus performantes
en font d'excellents garde-côtes ce que
recherchait en son temps l'australie le
contexte géopolitique a transformé ce
besoin en souhaitant disposer d'un
équipement à plus long rayon d'action
aux situations qu'a connu la france
puisqu'elle est le même à abandonner
cette technologie par conséquent cette
évolution
besoin australien d'etel prévisible
enfin dernier enseignement groupes
partagent analyse nombreux observateurs
cette crise doit nous conduire à
renforcer l'autonomie stratégique de
l'union européenne c'est une évidence si
l'europe ne veut pas être un otage des
décisions unilatérales comme celle que
paris vient de connaître un je vous
remercie
merci andré pour les républicains les
indépendants république et territoires
joël guerriau
merci président merci monsieur ministre
de vous prêter à cet échange
monsieur le ministre vous avez souligné
que la chine adopte d'attenté de deux
points pour être con pour essayer d'être
complémentaire avec mes collègues vous
avez souligné que la chine adopte depuis
un certain temps un comportement
alarmant elle renforce sa marine de
guerre que l' on le sait et revendique
des territoires voisins après hong kong
pékin affirmé à plusieurs reprises sa
détermination d'absorber le territoire
de taiwan les états unis à plusieurs
reprises ont affirmé leur soutien la
souveraine est taïwanaise masque mal
classés les conséquences de cette
décision de rupture
monsieur le ministre pensez vous que
l'alliance au cuss contribuera à freiner
ces comportements néocolonialistes
chinois au contraire risque d'accentuer
la menace alors même que la royal
australian navy
je devrai attendre jusqu'à dix ans
supplémentaires pour sa première
livraison semble-t-il en tout cas ça
sera plus long par rapport au calendrier
de naval groupe est bien dans quelle
mesure finalement l'extension de ce
délai vous irez à boulevard la menace
chinoise
c'est un vrai sujet j'aimerais que vous
entendre sur le sujet le deuxième point
pour compléter ce que le mes collègues
m'ont dit le conseil de l'union
européenne avait ouvert en mai 2010 8
mai des négociations au vu de l'accord
de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et l'australie fruit d'un
partenariat qui fut signé dix ans plus
tôt l'europe exporte aujourd'hui
massivement vers l'australie devenu en
2020 le troisième partenaire de l'union
européenne avec un excédent commercial
de 24 milliards d'euros en faveur de
l'europe
si je m'interroge si l'échec du contrat
du siècle avec l'australie signale
également l'enterrement de ce type
d'accord qui finalement nous est
bénéfique donc voilà les deux suspects
que j'aimerais que vous nous éclairer
sur la question bien sûr de taiwan sur
les conséquences que cela peut avoir et
puis deuxièmement sur cette question de
libre échange avec l'ue radi merci
monsieur le ministre en tout cas de
votre écoute merci joël enfin pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
guillaume gontard oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre cette
affaire et est grave comme vous l'avait
qualifié et pose de nombreuses questions
nous pouvons bien sûr regretter à la
fois le manque d'informations et
d'anticipation et ça a été rappelé
l'absence de contrôle du parlement dans
ce domaine quels signes avant coureurs
auraient pu alerter la france sur la
préparation d'une rupture de contrat et
d'une nouvelle alliance anglo saxon la
france était en effet présente au g7 en
juin où se serait conclue cette cette
alliance comment expliquer cet échec
d'autres réseaux diplomatiques et plus
encore de nos services de renseignement
on voit bien cette affaire est bien un
tournant stratégique et la constitution
d'un clivage entre la chine et les états
unis
et la france et le chef de la diplomatie
européenne joseph bourrel ont saisi
cette occasion pour s'exprimer une
nouvelle fois en faveur de la montée en
puissance de la défense européenne mais
il apparaît que peu de nos voisins
européens ou le même ont eu le même
réflexe pardon cela vous confirme qu'ils
sont encore nombreux à être favorables à
rester sous le giron des états unis
pouvez vous nous confirmer cela ou a
contrario certains états sont ils prêts
à revoir leur copie sur l'arrêt sur la
sur la relation et transatlantiques et
quel message souhaitez vous faire passer
notamment avec l'arrivée de la
présidence française en 2022
merci
à l'issue
torje trois collègues qui ont souhaité
poser une question est ce que je les
fais poser tout de suite et vous
répondrais globalement
oui
on peut prendre les trois les trois
questions complémentaires il n'y a pas
d'élément alors allons-y up
donc racheté mal
merci président moh sioniste merci pour
l'ensemble de ces remarques effet que
vous avez rappelé comédien français
lustres nous faisons la politique
d'autres géographies donc vous avez
raison le dire nous sommes une nation
indo pacifique et si je crois d'autant
plus pour cela que la france a été
humilié par action qui a été prise par
l'ensemble des pays à la fois
l'australie mais également avec les
américains et les îles et britannique
s'en est trop longue pas parce qu'on dit
mes collègues ce qui ne peut pas être
compliqué non pas vous avez parfaitement
rappeler les faits et je vous fais
confiance parce qu'il paraît être
compliqué c'est ce sentiment que nous
avons que vis-à-vis temps du contrat qui
prend du temps à négocier un nouveau
contrat que vis-à-vis de l'alliance qui
a été annoncée le même jour vous l'avez
évoqué au cuss le sentiment c'est que
pendant des mois et des moins bons en
tout cas des semaines
personne que ce soit ici ou là bas ou
dans les services ambassades n'a pu
entendre cru vu ce qui pouvait se passer
et c'est ça que je crois qu'ils qui
aujourd'hui la question que nous nous
posons légitimement et c'est celle que
j'ai
ouï mais je
je vous ai écouté jusqu'au bout je vais
essayer de terminer mais il n'y a pas de
sujet mais après radio j'entends ce que
vous dites et je reviendrai sur propos
très différents de ceux du présent
public mais en tout cas même si c'est un
poignard dans le dos on peut
s'interroger sur notre capacité je crois
que c'est un peu l'objet aussi de cette
commission enquête sur nos services nos
capacités à entendre voir ce qui a pu se
passer et c'est je crois la dont ne
voyez pas contrairement à votre collègue
que j'ai un thé au jasmin d'hyères un
procès d'intention c'est une des cités
de comprendre pour ne pas avoir revu
donc ça c'est mon premier point deuxième
point de la saison c'est pour vous nous
confirmer que effectivement personne n'a
vu russe eut entendu quoi que ce soit
deuxième chose c'est sur la question du
différentiel vous parlez avec justesse
vous l'avez dit là un coup de poignard
dans le dos une trahison une crise
diplomatique et quand je lis le le
communiqué de presse de l'elysée et je
trouve un vrai delta et c'est aussi une
des interrogations que nous avons plus
que le président de la république le
sentiment est peut-être que vous me
corrigerez c'est que maintenant qu'à une
information préalable
on peut en discuter mais c'est je crois
assez loin de la position vous avez vous
même portée d'autant plus que le
lendemain encore une fois de cette de ce
coup de fil il y a comme l'a dit aux
déchets n'y ait d'autres il ya quand
même cette réunion cette nouvelle
réunion sur la zone indo pacifique et la
france est toujours pas invité donc là
l'autre question c'est est ce que tout
le monde est bien aligné dans le vallon
français est en tout cas comment voyez
vous le fait que les états unis encore
une fois au delà du premier du contrat
font une nouvelle alliance je les dis
hocus et relance une autre alliance quad
sans pour autant jamais intégré la
france en tout cas échanges avec la
france sur ces questions là je vous
remercie
merci rachid philippe folliot
merci monsieur le président les
relations entre la france et l'australie
sont très anciennes halles sont
sportives rugbystique
dans ce dans ce cadre-là gésir nous
avons reçu un coup de poing un
australien un plaquage à retardement
américaine et une vicieuse fourchette
britannique
vous avez dit monsieur monsieur le
ministre et vous avez bien souligné que
cet accord relatif donc au sous-marin
était un des volets de l'accord
stratégique qui avait été signé entre la
france et l'australie nous avait dit que
ceux ci auraient des conséquences
notamment sur la renégociation peut être
de quelques éléments ou la remise en
cause peut-être de quelques éléments de
cet accord est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous dire de manière plus précise ce
qu'il en est et quelle va être notre
stratégie jusqu'où nous allons aller
dans le cadre la redéfinition de cet
accord stratégique et monsieur président
bien fait de le souligner
nous sommes voisins de l'australie le
pays avec lequel la france la frontière
maritime la plus longue c'est au monde
c'est l'australie par le biais donc de
la nouvelle calédonie entre autres
donc ça c'est le premier pas le deuxième
point c'est sur les conséquences de nos
collègues a dit mot
un
jeu qui est un enjeu essentiel par
rapport aux problématiques de
prolifération et que donc dans ce cadre
là il ya eu une conséquence indirecte de
ce qui s'est passé de cette nouvelle
alliance au caucus c'est finalement au
travers d'une organisation militaire qui
ne dit pas son nom mais qui de fait en
est une ou tout au moins sur un plan
diplomatique qui est l'organisation de
la coopération de shanghai et le fait
que la chine que part dont la chine oui
et ses alliés russes et pakistanais
entre autres aux nouveaux partenaires et
kelly rente et donc la question c'est de
savoir est ce que ceci ne va pas nous
affaiblir dans le cadre de la stratégie
internationale qui est la nôtre de non
prolifération notamment en iran au
regard du fait que les américaines ont
octroyé un certain nombre de moyens donc
atomique aux
australiennes et donc d'une manière
indirecte peut favoriser une forme de
prolifération
merci philippe et yannick vaugrenard
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces
informations ou ces compléments
d'information
on reviendra très probablement dans
d'autres auditions sur le fait que la
france avait connaissance depuis déjà à
mi juin de difficultés dans le cadre du
contrat ici le président de laval groupe
est allé s'est déplacé en australie à
accepter leur style 14 au 15 jours à
l'abri du covin c'est bien qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui se passait et c'était
problématique
la question qui se posera nous on aura
l'occasion de l'évoquer
pourtant d'autres deux auditions c'est
comment les services de renseignement à
ce moment là dès lors qu'on avait ces
informations n'ont pas pu avoir
d'informations complémentaires mais je
pense qu'on verra ça plus tard au delà
du coup de balai a bon dos le principe
du coup de main à van loo c'est qu'on ne
voit pas venir bien sûr sauf que
au delà du texte moi c'est le contexte
que je voudrais sur lequel je voudrais
revenir pourquoi nous aviez historique
en quelque sorte nous ont fait subir
cette humiliation
pour quelles raisons
qui pouvaient dépasser cette amitié
historique entre l'amérique et la france
a ses règles et change me pose tout
d'abord la première réponse qu'on peut
avoir me semble-t-il avait beaucoup
mieux d'humilité c'est que l'amérique a
été humilié à kaboul
il c'est l'échec de kaboul qui peut être
a fait que les américains se sont
précipités dans cette mise en scène avec
les britanniques et les australiens la
première des raisons peut-être la
deuxième c'est le comportement de
l'australie je pense que l'australie a
préféré sacrifier sa souveraineté pour
mettre en avant sa sécurité
et vu de l'australie peut-être est-il
plus sûr pour elle d'être assuré de la
défense américaine objectivement que de
la défense française
surtout que la métropole ne fait pas
beaucoup de cas différents du référendum
leurs yeux en nouvelle calédonie sur les
de l'indépendance ou pas de la nouvelle
calédonie est donc à travers ça ne
pensez vous pas monsieur le ministre que
nous assistons véritablement un tournant
géopolitique majeur depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale les états unis
aujourd'hui se détermine non pas en
fonction des valeurs universelles que
nous évoquions depuis 1945 mais en
fonction d'intérêts économiques majeures
qu'ils ont à faire face avec la chine
est donc dans ce combat en quelque sorte
présents et futurs avec la fine
que pesant nous d'une certaine manière
il m'a surprise est grande et c'est là
où j'en viens à ma question contenu
cette évolution géopolitique majeur
compte tenu du fait que les américains
aujourd'hui ne réagisse qu'en fonction
des intérêts économiques qui leur sont
propres america farce que ce soit 30 joe
biden maiden rien n'est changé et donc
compte tenu de cela comment se fait-il
au delà de l'humiliation que nous avait
que nous avons subi les conséquences
géopolitiques que nous pouvons constater
comment se fait-il que le président de
la république vous êtes seul vous avez
vous laisse vous avez laissés seuls
assurés en quelque sorte la défense de
cette humiliation comment se fait-il
alors qu'il ya eu ce que l'onu s'est
réuni quelque temps après que lé
président de la république n'ait pas
saisi cette occasion majeure me semble
utile pour indiquer qu'une subissions
une évolution géopolitique stratégique
fondamentale est en quelque sorte de
fête de faire entendre la voix de la
france
je me disais
parler des deux bouddhas
dirait des forces politiques françaises
j'imagine pas que dans de telles
circonstances le général de gaulle où
françois mitterrand se serait tu
presqu'une semaine il n'aurait pas
choisi ensuite la tribune de l'onu pour
s'adresser finalement au monde et voilà
je voulais savoir qu'il est votre
sentiment je vous avoir été désappointé
par cette non l'intervention que je
trouve désolante pour la france
merci derniers intervenants alain
joyandet oui merci à monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
pour toutes les explications vous avez
bien voulu nous donner
j'avais deux questions mais l'une vient
d'être traités donc je ne vais pas
redire ce que viennent de 10 mon
collègue en termes de tournant
stratégique peut être majeur que nous
sommes en train de vivre et j'avais une
question peut être un peu plus
subsidiaire et qui concerne
particulièrement monsieur le ministre
navale groupe parce que on parle on
parle évidemment d'accord
intergouvernemental
ou d'accords intergouvernementaux on
parle de stratégie politique entre les
états mais derrière il ya comme un
contrat commercial et technique si j'ai
bien entendu si j'ai bien entendu vous
avez dit que le contrat commercial avait
été dénoncée auprès de notre groupe mais
vous n'aviez pas encore de dénonciation
de l'accord intergouvernemental si je
suis fidèle à ce que j'ai cru comprendre
ça veut quand même bien dire que
derrière tout ça il ya comme un contrat
commercial et technique entre une
entreprise qui est un fournisseur et un
client j'ai quand même et c'est quand
même le fonds du ce comme le fond du
sujet même si tout ça est béni par les
états j'ai quand même du mal à croire
que les gens qui au quotidien géraient
ce dossier à l'intérieur de nava groupe
n'ont rien vu venir ou ne savaient rien
ou alors ça veut dire qu'il ya des mois
qu'il se passe plus rien entre navale
groupe les extraits les australiens donc
je pense qu'on a une part d'informations
qui nous manque parce que ça serait
peut-être important aussi pour le
gouvernement et pour vous même de
véritablement savoir ce qui s'est passé
au sein de neuf groupes pour que un
problème de management éventuels ou
technique à l'intérieur d'une entreprise
ne se transforme pas en conflit
stratégique mondial et moi j'ai quand
même beaucoup de mal à croire ce qu'on
nous dit concernant le niveau
d'information qui a été celui auquel le
gouvernement a eu accès et donc tout à
l'heure on parlait de commission
denquête moi je suis pas un fan des
commission denquête je pense que dans
l'intérêt du pays il faut absolument
qu'on sache réellement ce qui s'est
passé à l'intérieur de navarre groupe
est ce qu'il ya eu des négligences qui
finalement ont conduit à la dénonciation
du contrat je ne sais pas je n'accuse
pas je n'accuse pas puisque nous ne
savons pas il ya quand même un problème
parce que vous n'avez quasiment pas
parlé de 9,1 groupe dans vos propos vous
avez fait beaucoup de politiques
beaucoup de stratégie c'est tout à fait
normal c'est votre rôle sur votre rôle
mais je pense qu'il est de notre devoir
à nous ici que me au parlement et vous
de savoir véritablement quelle part de
responsabilité porte navale groupe pour
l'avenir pour l'avenir stratégique parce
qu'un aval groupés en charge aussi
d'autres d'autres opérations navales
groupe est-il irréprochable dans cette
affaire est ce que ce n'est qu'une
question de stratégie politique et de
nouvelles stratégies politiques
notamment des états unis d'amérique ou
bien ce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
problèmes tout simplement techniques qui
ont conduit la dénonciation d'un contrat
qui du coup entraîne une crise
diplomatique
ce serait à la fois inquiétant mais
aussi un peu rassurant pour les
capacités de
la diplomatie française ait nos services
de renseignement merci merci alain
monsieur le ministre voit la
question je vais essayer de répondre
papa individuellement non non recoupées
un peu les lycées la formation les
questions
moi j'ai été frappé par
l'article de monsieur turnball ce matin
premier ministre avec lequel j'avais
signé l'accord
antérieurement
en 2016 il dit
nos design
nos costing nos contracte
c'est à dire que dans ce qui a été dit
et et parler les trois est dans ce que
disent les autorités actuelles
australienne
il n'y a pas de projet
pas de coup pas de contrat
et quand je disais tout à l'heure c'est
le saut dans l'inconnu
les australiens font leur choix
mais la réalité elle est bien là et
quand je ne sais qui monsieur vaugrenard
disait et les des australiens ont
choisir la sécurité plutôt que la
souveraineté je crains qu'il n'ait ni
l'un ni l'autre
parce que ce que l'on a peut remarquer
c'est que dans le déclaratif
de détroit
il est simplement dit on va faire une
étude de 18 mois pour essayer de définir
ce qu'on va faire
c'est à dire que c'est un projet de
projet un projet pour savoir s'il va y
avoir un projet est pour cette raison là
on rompt un contrat qui était en cours
c'est ça la réalité
et cette observation de ce premier mais
j'observe aussi comme le ckd il a dit
que d'autres premier ministre australien
différences politiques mettant deux
volets de la même filière politique que
monsieur morrison dit ça avec beaucoup
de force
c'est même impressionnant
qui le disent publiquement ce matin
donc tout ça n'est pas fini
et quand
j'interroge mon collègue blinken sur ce
qui est vraiment décidée ce qui est
vraiment décidée c'est une étude pour
savoir si on comment on va faire
et quand on connaît
l'histoire de l'australie avec le
nucléaire
on est en droit de s'interroger
et je pense que les australiens aussi
vont s'interroger en tout cas les néo
zélandais loger tout de suite
donc j'appelle votre attention sur cela
et sur le fait que
si les australiens avaient décidé
d'acquérir leur souveraineté non leur
liberté de décision du temps de la
signature du contrat c'était pour des
sous marins océaniques
c'était le barracuda versus
conventionnels parce que la propulsion
nucléaire n'était pas envisageable
est elle envisageable aujourd'hui quelle
culture nucléaire à ce pays comment est
ce que ce pays va se doter d'une
propulsion nucléaire
c'est pas à moi de répondre mais que le
premier single le disent c'est quand
même intéressant
il n'y a pas de projet
il ya une volonté de faire une étude
et pour cela dans le même mouvement
auront un contrat
ont fait perdre la confiance à un allié
et ont défini une stratégie
confrontation elle avec la chine dans le
même acte et c'est pour ça que je
voudrais que j'avais eu ma propre aux
traits géostratégique par rapport à
cette analyse parce que fait trois en
même temps dans le même acte
j'appelle votre attention sur ça parce
que tout ça n'est à mon avis pas finir
c'est un vrai saut dans l'inconnu je
voudrais dire aussi que tai chi chi qui
a été l on citera lit que
choix de la france à l'époque
entre 4 concurrence musiciens des quatre
concurrents a fait l'objet depuis le
début d'une bataille de presse contre
nous il le sait très bien monsieur
d'origine il
est animé par le groupe murdoch
qui pop qui tient 70% de la presse
australienne et qui depuis le début
avant même
l'accord puisque toute une série
d'actions qui avaient été engagées la
négociation a duré deux ans
c'est aux définitions souviens très bien
il y avait cette campagne contre nous
qui s'est poursuivie en permanence si
bien que à mon avis il y a une il faut
bien distinguer deux choses dans les
vérifications les interrogations que
vous faites moi j'ai pas porter de
jugement sur ce que de la manière dont
vous allez fonctionné je n'ai eu aucun
blocage sur en tout cas ce qui dépend de
moi pour vous auditionné nos
ambassadeurs sans problème y compris je
pense le patron de laval groupe qui
pourra abonnés lésés seraient des
renseignements supplémentaires mais
il faut pas confondre deux sujets sur
lesquels la presse
australienne
a essayé de jouer qui une partie de la
presse australien qui permettent à
parfois des confusions
il y a eu
au courant de cette année la discussion
à partir de c'était
l'accord sur le design c'était en juin
et septembre 2019 sur l'a9 en australie
c'est à ce moment là une discussion une
fois de l'accord est passé une
discussion sur les étapes
et dans la discussion sur les étapes il
y avait en particulier la définition du
design de du sous marin de la 2e étape
qui a pris un certain temps parce qu'il
y avait trois sujets en discussion à la
fois les coûts
à la fois la part australienne dans le
dans le programme et la fois les délais
tout ça dans un contexte de co vide qui
ne faisait que des headley a été retardé
et ça a été animée par une partie de la
presse australienne ils ont ça n'avance
pas assez vite etc et c'est pour ces
raisons là que monsieur pommelet malgré
l'accord vite et aller passer un mois en
australie pour régler les problèmes qui
ont été réglés et il est logique que
dans des contrats sur une durée aussi
longue cinquante ans quand on définit le
design on prend un peu de temps à savoir
les délais le prix et est aussi la
répartition des tâches pour la partie
australienne ou et pour la partie
française je pense que mon idole dans le
futur si d'aventuriers un futur
des discussions sur la partie
australienne ne pas être facile en tout
cas parce que le ce qu'on n'a pas mesuré
c'est que le fait l'accord soit rompu ça
veut dire aussi que les aides des
entreprises australiennes qui
travaillent sur le projet se trouve
aussi son activité donc il faut pas
confondre ce point là qui a fait l'objet
de l'accord qui a été confirmé par la
lettre du 15
de 15 septembre pas la lettre de
monsieur morrison au président de la
république mais la lettre du ministre de
la défense à laval go pour dire c'est
parfait on y va à fond
le même jour ce qui veut dire que en
termes d'information donc je ne savais
pas qu'il y avait autre chose ou alors
ils mentent je dis ça pue ou alors vous
mentez je vous dis pourquoi m'entendre
si le cas septembre le ministre de
défense australien annonce que tout ça
va bien on continue et que le même jour
le premier ministre dit au président de
la république bat on arrête il se passe
il ya quand même quelque chose qui va
pas et donc
donc
il y a là une interrogation mais natale
groupe n'avait pas du tout identifier en
quoi que ce soit qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui se passait derrière
nous non plus
et personne
il ya eu un débat technique sur le
projet né qui était un débat sur le
sous-marin conventionnel qui avait que
se poursuive et donc à partir d'une
annonce du cas ça veut dire qu'on
continue et
l'autre sujet c'est qu'on change de
propulsion mais jamais on n'a eu jeudi
aux propos introductifs de demandes à
cet égard on sait faire
mais pour personne nous a jamais demandé
et s'il y a eu
le cherche d'un situation d'une nouvelle
d'une nouvelle donne
elle s'est développée en comité
extrêmement restreint
j'ai bien entendu tout à l'heure que
vous souhaitiez le parlement sur
largement informé le parlement américain
n'était pas informé ni les présentes
commission qui avait une alternative
personnes donc ça s'est passé en tout
petit cercle quand j'ai dit tout petit
cercle et tout petit cercle ce qui
explique d'ailleurs pourquoi
la présentation publique de l'accord et
le compte du dakota aussi faible parce
que si vous voulez aller au delà du fait
que vous dites on va faire une étude de
18 mois eh ben à ce moment là vous y
trouverez des ventes et qui se passe
quelque chose
bon vous pourrez interroger nos
ambassadeurs mais c'est globalement ce
que ce que nous avons vécu
et que là ce moment là il faudrait pour
aller plus loin que les services de
renseignement français utilisent des
méthodes ne sont pas les méthodes que
nous utilisons nous mêmes
ce que nous faisons pas
j'ai pas si pourri ce que je veux dire
et que la réunion de cardiff bay
lui n'a pas été informé qu'il y avait
une réunion à trois qui se passait
randonnée
même si c'est sans doute là que les
enjeux principaux ont été évoqués
je vais passer alors j'ai essayé de
répondre à d'autres sujets
[Musique]
sur
sur la relation sur l'accord
intergouvernemental
je vous le lit
la partie la plus d'actualité
dans le cas d'une dénonciation par l'une
des parties l'effet de la dénonciation
n'est pas immédiat les parties se
consultent pendant une durée maximum de
12 mois dans le but de permettre le
maintien en vigueur de l'accord si aucun
accord n'est trouvé pendant ces douze
mois et qu'une partie n'accepte pas le
maintien en vigueur de l'accord alors la
dénonciation prend effet 24 mois après
la réception de la notification écrite
de la dénonciation
je soumets cette partie de l'accord que
j'ai signé à votre réflexion mais je
soumets aussi à la presse australienne
sur
nous avons nous avions des relations
avec
l'australie qui avait été convenu sous
la forme d'un partenariat stratégique
qui a été signé le 3 mars 2017 par les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
deux pays tu es mon prédécesseur et
ensuite le dispositif a été lancé lors
de la visite du président la république
à sydney en mai 2010huit s'appelle
l'initiative affinity avec toute une
série de programmes que nous avons
commencé à mettre en oeuvre des
programmes de formation des programmes
universitaires
des programmes de lutte contre le
terrorisme des programmes liées au
spatial des programmes liés à la
préservation de la diversité
sur des programmes liés à la résilience
des récifs coralliens des programmes
liés aux métaux critiques y compris les
terres les terres rares ces programmes
liés à la coopération sur les
technologies à basse émission dont
l'hydrogène à partir d'énergies
renouvelables
c'était le affinity un affinity 2 et
affinity 2 a été convenu avec ma
collègue payne dans une réunion que nous
avons tenue à londres
il ya trois mois quatre mois j'ai pu au
mois de mai dernier pour assurer le
suivi de tout cela donc nous avions une
relation très forte qui allait se
renforcer qui se renforçaient nos
différents domaines moi je suis allé à
adélaïde il y avait déjà à l'université
d'adélaïde des partenariats qui étaient
visibles vivace
palpable qui se mettaient qui se mettait
en place c'est tout cela que l'on va
surtout cela qu'on va revoir notre copie
et que nous travaillons actuellement sur
savoir quel va être le
le type de relation que nous allons
avoir ensuite avec avec l'australie
sur
la question importante de la
le traité d'interdiction des armes
nucléaires
on parle de propulsion l'arrêt on parle
pas de d'armement nucléaire il n'empêche
que les contours de l'initiative que
nous avons entendu
nécessite des précisions pour l'instant
je ne les a pas et l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
doit être appliquée pour définir avec
l'australie les mesures les paramètres
qui permettront de s'assurer de
l'adéquation des coopérations envisagées
avec l' architecture international de
non-prolifération et en particulier de
régime des garanties de la hure ce n'est
pas
le traité de non prolifération n'est pas
touché par cette question de propulsion
nucléaire mais
si d'autres états utilisent et devait
utiliser cette coopération comme
argument pour légitimité des violations
ça entraînerait évidemment des
perturbations géopolitiques
quelques-uns ont cité l'iran c'est vrai
que cet exemple là ne
ne va pas être n'est pas un signe
d'apaisement et quand l'un d'entre vous
disais je crois c'est pierre laurent
que
la situation vous aviez trouvé les
propos graves oui c'est grave mais
d'autres ont dit monsieur gattolin après
quelques autres oui la saison est gravé
et on n'en sort pas comme ça
nous avons
dit dans dans le génie des propos de
départ qu' il fallait des actes et que
ça prendrait du temps et ça serait de
l'exigence nous avons identifié trois
secteurs sur lesquels nous devons
travailler ensemble commençons à le
faire dans nos relations avec les états
unis mais ça prendra du temps
et c'est vrai que il y a je ne sus batna
qui parlait d'une boussole stratégique
américaine et plusieurs d'autres
plusieurs autres ont relevé que je le
dis dans mon propos introductif que les
états unis se
fait des choix stratégiques
depuis 2011 qui se recentrait sur leur
aux intérêts fondamentaux c'est à dire
que ça s'est traduit par le retrait
d'irak le retrait d'afghanistan par
l'évolution de leur positionnement dans
le golfe et qui se concentre sur la
chine est seulement sur la chine au
détriment des intérêts jugés secondaires
et ça ça transcende les administrations
obama 30 des bananes
ça se regroupent sa s'oriente vers la
est dans une logique de confrontation
elle qui à mon avis doit être prise
comme sa part par la chine
notre logique est différente je vais
exposer tout à l'heure elle veut être un
modèle alternatif pour
marquer nos positions et on sait très
bien la menace chinoise mais en même
temps montrer aux autres pays de la zone
est-ce que c'est comme ça le sujet
principal qu' il y a une autre manière
de faire est qu'on peut en respectant
leur propre souveraineté agir pour qu'il
y ait une stratégie indo pacifique qui
les concernent dont ils se sentent
partie prenante et moi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce que certains ont dit
sur le déclin de la france dans la zone
nous avons un partenariat très fort avec
l'inde
c'est la zone nous avons un partenariat
très fort avec l'indonésie c'est la zone
nous avons un partenariat très fort avec
singapour c'est la zone nous avons un
partenaire très fort avec la malaisie
c'est la zone mais ces pays là il va le
leur souveraineté leur autonomie donc
nous sommes dans cette discussion là je
vais me rendre prochainement en
indonésie mais comme partenaire respecté
et reconnu et peut-être encore plus
reconnu maintenant que nous avons pris
ces positions à l'égard de ce qui s'est
passé avec hocus cela mène d'ailleurs
situation avec le japon le quad n'est
pas une alliance le quad c'est une
système de consultation 1 entre quatre
pays qui se rencontrent régulièrement le
nos amis indiens ne sont absolument pas
avoir à rentrer dans ce type d'alliance
donc nous avons des relations régulières
avec l'inde j'ai rencontré mon collègue
à à new york et le partenariat entre la
france et l'inde et apportera
extrêmement forte y compris en matière
d'armement n'est pas n'est pas
uniquement
jeu non prolifération ton monsieur
laurent j'ai répondu
oui j'ai dit monsieur guéant ce sont des
sous marins océaniques
sur des sous-marins aussi un excellent
et barracuda propulsion conventionnelle
mais avec les taux de le niveau
d'acoustique extrêmement performant qui
le représente ce qui fait que la
démonstration que nous avons fait c'est
vraiment des sous marins océaniques
c'est pour ça que nous avons choisi et
c'est bon ça n'ont pas choisi les autres
si si ce taux défini souviens bien
c'était parce que nous avions
l'affirmation océaniques que nous avons
été choisis
l'efficacité et la réalité au scénic
parce qu'on peut leur on peut le
démontrer
pendant les trente sociale ouais ai dit
que nous sous marin avait fait la preuve
de vision ils ont tant de capacités 30
ce ne sont pas des souvent de protection
de voisinage va
très bien
je sais plus si alors sur
masquer des skimmers qui me frappe
vraiment par rapport à la question
centrale à l'égard de la chine
c'est que on ne
pourra être en
alternative avec la chine que si on a
des accords avec l'ensemble des pays qui
respectent leur souveraineté et qui
permettent de développer un modèle qui
soit une réponse est
contradictoire avec ce que proposent les
chinois dans la zone et c'est une
rupture de cette logique là qui est à
laquelle nous assistons maintenant
tout
simplement que chacun sache bien que
lorsque je m'exprime personne n'imagine
que je m'exprime sans l'accord du
président de la république
répond monsieur vaugrenard et que
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
qui s'est tenue cette année elle était
très particulière parce qu'elle était à
la fois en présentiel et en hybride et
donc il y avait relativement de peu de
chefs d'état présents et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le présenterai bling la
déléguée pour que je représente la
france à ce moment là on ça n'imaginez
pas que ça allait coïncider avec
l'annoncé de locus
chez président je crois que j'ai essayé
de dire l'essentiel
[Musique]
merci monsieur min j'aurai terminé par
une dernière question plus prosaïque
parce que des derniers derrière cette
problématique a quand même une dimension
du temps le président américain est à
personnalités certainement honorable
mais enfin je pense qu'il n'est pas
lui-même préoccupé par ce qui se passera
dans dix ou dans quinze ans ce qu'il
veut c'est que dans la confrontation
avec la chine qu'ils lancent comme une
priorité il se donne les moyens est ce
que le résultat le plus concret derrière
ce rideau de fumée de d'études d'une
étude est ce que ça va pas être tout
simplement que les australiens vont
accueillir des sous marins nucléaires
américains pendant un temps x plus zen
avant que des générations nouvelles de
sous-marins peut-être dur est construit
avec les anglais pour remplacer le
fameux astuces est-ce que le premier
effet de cette affaire c'est pas d'avoir
dans le pacifique sud pour les
américains une base qui s'appelle
adélaïde où je ne sais où et qui va
accueillir des sous marins nucléaires
américains dans lequel on mettra un
petit peu de
demar de sous-mariniers australien pour
dire voilà mais en fait est-ce que les
faits concrets est ce que la manoeuvre
n'est pas au fond c'est la changement de
pied de l'australie qui se fait
convainquent par les états unis on veut
tous l'australie craint la chine nous
ils nous l'ont répété tellement de fois
et donc ils se prêtent à ce jeu qui
consiste à accueillir vraisemblement des
soins car sinon les hypothèses c'était
2030 chez nous mais parti comme on
essaie 2040 monsieur by donne je sais
pas si dur 2040 il est en train de
bouleverser l'échiquier se fâcher avec
des alliés solides pour une échéance qui
arrive en 2000 car moi c'était comme
dans un poste il ment car il manque une
pièce et est le facteur temps
est quand même au centre de la réflexion
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent concrètement
un point d'appui vis à vis de la chine
c'est très simple on va attendre on va
attendre que les choses se tassent on va
calmer un peu les alliés puis comme par
hasard on va voir un puis deux puis
trois peut être quatre j'en sais rien
sous marins américains qui vont venir
relâché et dire à la chine moi je vois
l'ambassadeur chinois demain je vais
voir ce qu'il va raconter dire à la
chine maintenant on est en bas la voyez
vous voyez où ça on est là
c'est une question je ne ferai pas de
commentaires puisque nous sommes à voilà
c'est une somme en séance publique mais
ces parlementaires peuvent dire non
parfois ils vont trouver des bêtises
mais voilà c'était une idée qui me
passait par l'eba automatiquement des
bêtises mais je n'ai pas dit que c'était
des bêtises je ne faisais pas de
commentaire monsieur le président vous
sur vos observations la danse dans cette
configuration très bien je vous pourrez
en faire dans d'autres configurations
dépend là on va durer ce clore la gueule
la partie publique de cette réunion
comme ça si vous si tel ou tel veut
continuer les échanges c'est tout à fait
possible merci monsieur le ministre de
de nous avoir donné ces éléments il
concourra à notre meilleur il concourt à
notre meilleure information
comme cela a été évoqué ici ou là je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un long
travail que la commission va essayer de
faire pour bien comprendre comment ces
différents éléments s'articule et encore
une fois je pense que loin de l'idée de
pointer tel ou tel même s'il peut y
avoir des dysfonctionnements notre
interrogation au jour d'aujourd'hui vous
nous avez donné une assurance moi je la
prends évidemment mais c'est l'avenir de
la france dans l'inde opacifie surtout
et je suis désolé de redire cette
préoccupation la sphère de la nouvelle
calédonie nous préoccupe beaucoup
beaucoup et moi les contacts de haut
niveau que j'ai eu avec des australiens
1 et me dise cette affaire interpelle
l'australie ils disent mais voilà un
pays qui ne se soucient qui ne se
soucient pas beaucoup de l'avenir dans
ces territoires qui est de l'autre côté
de chez nous et donc est ce que c'est
mais effectivement les choses peuvent
interagir non dans les deux sens pour
faire je vous laisse queen is à quoi
allait toujours vision nous sommes
maintenant cette séance est terminée
donc la vision va être suspendue je vous
remercie sur collègue monsieur le
ministre merci infiniment et nous
continuerons je le rappelle avec
l'audition de madame la ministre des
armées le président pommelé président de
naval gros bernard emié le patron de la
dgse et le caser sur d'autres
rendez-vous et entretien
nous on ne l'exclût pas parce que on est
intéressé de savoir comment l'ambassade
notre ambassadeur à canberra a vécu
cette séquence il doit quand même en
avoir un souvenir ému
merci à tous bonne soirée